moon knight is the upcoming disney plus
series that stars oscar isaac as mark
spector aka moon knight one of the more
unique characters in marvel comics this
former mercenary suffers from a
dissociative identity disorder that has
manifested in different ways over the
years in one iteration of the character
spectre saw visions of spider-man
wolverine and captain america guiding
him as he fought crime based on the
official trailer it looks like the show
will put its own spin on the character
for starters the series begins with mark
living under another of his identities a
bumbling museum gift shop employee named
steven grant who seemingly has no memory
of his other selves one day stephen
begins experiencing dream-like visions
that convince him he's losing his mind
but then he realizes the visions are
actually real i can't tell the
difference
between my waking life
and dreams in some of them steven
appears as a grey cloak to moon knight a
vigilante for the egyptian moon guard
konchu any superhero is only as good as
their villain and the official moon
knight trailer finally revealed who the
moon knight will be facing dr arthur
harrow even die hard marvel heads might
not be familiar with the not so good
doctor so here's a quick explainer
dr harrow appears in just one issue of
the moon knight comics the second issue
of volume 2 which was published in 1985.
in the comics he's a nobel prize
nominated researcher who specializes in
pain tolerance upon his nomination for
the nobel prize in medicine he begins to
draw the suspicions of one doctor
victoria graham she doesn't believe he's
been able to accomplish all that he's
done on animal test subjects alone she
makes a shocking realization he's been
using human test subjects against their
will with experiments inspired by nazi
researchers who wanted to make humans
invulnerable to pain
all of this is spearheaded by the
sinister think tank known as omnium
fortunately dr grayl has back up in a
big way mark specter receives a vision
informing him of dr harrow's true
intentions
the two team up to break into dr
harrow's laboratory to stop his evil
ways once and for all although dr harrow
escapes in the story he hasn't popped up
in the comics since but he's about to
make a grand debut once again in the
disney plus series moon knight while
it's easy to catch up with the law
surrounding dr harrow it's unclear how
much good it will do in the lead up to
the latest marvel show based on the
trailer alone it would seem there are
some distinct differences between the dr
harrow from the comics and the one being
played by ethan hawke to begin the comic
version of dr harrow suffers from a
condition called trigeminal neuralgia
which results in facial paralysis it
also causes the left side of his mouth
to remain in a permanent grimace it
would seem like the disney plus
iteration doesn't have the disease but
anything could happen over the course of
6 episodes additionally the moonlight
trailer suggests dr harrow will be a
cult leader as well as a researcher if
the legions of fans bowing to his whim
are any indication ethan hawke himself
actually confirmed that cult leader
status in an interview with seth meyers
the actor stated i've based my character
on david correct have you really
yeah koresh was the leader of the branch
davidians claiming to be a final prophet
he played an integral role in the waco
siege of 1993
ultimately resulting in his death in
terms of what calls dr harrow could lead
in the disney plus series it's possible
it's the cult of kancho in the comics
this is the egyptian deity who gives
moon knight his powers and in the modern
day versions of the character he has a
cult of his own after all dr harrow
encourages mark spector to embrace the
chaos so perhaps he wants to use the
next avatar of konshu for his own
nefarious ends more will undoubtedly be
revealed about the character in the
following weeks otherwise disney plus
and marvel studios have kept their plans
for the character and the raps we'll
know more when moon knight premieres on
march 30th 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one